these 36 dramatic situations
are every element that is in any story
anywhere
and a lot of people said that's insane i
could come up with way more and they
tried to come up with a list and they
couldn't even get to 24.
they were like actually it's better than
i thought
jeff can you give us an overview of the
36 dramatic situations
the 36 dramatic situations is really a
brainstorming tool
it works with elements
that are common in storytelling
like madness disaster ambition those
types of things
it was created by an italian playwright
named carlo gotze in the 1700s
and it was endorsed by gerta and
schiller
and on the strength of those
endorsements that hung around for about
150 years
until a guy named george poulty turned
it into a book in 1916.
and then it picked up some steam again
but it's
it's unknown by many people and
i've met a lot of people who said they
had the book but could never make heads
or tails out of it
it's it's basically
what gatsey said was that all stories
consist of these
basic 36 human emotional
conflicts and there are things like
ambition
madness conflict with a god the
necessity of sacrificing loved ones
and it's very similar in nature to the
periodic table of elements in chemistry
where you know carbon hydrogen all that
stuff
so with the periodic table of elements
you could describe anything in this room
quite
completely from one point of view like
this table is carbon
hydrogen oxygen whatever all the
elements that are in it
you can describe it quite completely
from that one point of view
that's only one point of view but that's
getting right at the elements that are
in it and
in storytelling it's the same thing
where you can say
okay this story has madness conflict
with a god
vengeance taken for kindred upon kindred
um and there's different so
different active elements in any given
story
which is useful because it helps you
when you're starting out with a story
where you can
like for instance let's look at your
derrick story idea again
so we'd be looking at what would be let
me just get my
book here because
it's easy to go down the one sheet oh
great for these
so here's a list of the
here's a list of the 36 dramatic
situations
just listed simply so
looking at it in terms of derek's story
so deliverance rescuing or being rescued
crime pursued by vengeance pursuit
disaster revolt daring enterprise the
enigma the riddle or the mystery
obtaining madness he may be like losing
his mind as
being pressed into this dilemma into
like what do i do here
i'm in love with her she's offering me a
life of adventure
but i have to betray my most core values
but
are those core values based on something
that were real or was i snookered into
guarding criminals i don't know i'm
losing my mind
these are all just story possibilities
some of it is like
some of what i was doing were elements
that are already active
in the story idea before it's even
touched
you want to see what you've got it's
like taking inventory
like what are the elements that are
already active in it and there may be
a lot more than you thought there were
which is good
um self-sacrifice for an ideal
all sacrificed for a passion the
necessity of sacrificing loved ones is
gonna have to give her up
rivalry of superior and inferior that's
always a good one
because it's so subjective of like who's
the superior and who's the inferior
and it's completely point of view
sensitive and it can even flicker back
and forth of who has the upper hand
in any given situation uh discovery of
the dishonor of a loved one if he's
finding out that
she is you know a criminal obstacles to
love is very active in this story but
sit before it's even touched
and enemy loved falling in love with
someone who turns out to be your enemy
or enemy love can be fascination with an
enemy
um or coming to understand your enemy
or falling in love with your enemy that
kind of thing
ambition is very central in this story
because
derek is stuck in this rut and he has
ambitions for more but he doesn't know
how to
get there and she may awaken ambition in
him
or he may have a curious lack of
ambition like why don't i care that i'm
stuck in this
rut or why do i care that she's dragging
me down this
weird road so it can be the
very absence of one of these situations
like you if you look at a character's
ambition it may be that their ambition
is
wildly out of proportion and getting
them in trouble or they could have
utterly no
ambition which is out of proportion for
a given situation it's
curious i'm like why does this person
genuinely not
care which way they go is so it's like
it can be the presence or absence of
these things too
that can be suggestive these are really
suggestive
elements for brainstorming so you can
see that
some of what i'm doing here is as i'm
going down the list and i'm thinking
about this
story it's helping with the what if
i'm seeing what is already there before
the story was ever even touched
the elements that it showed up with and
what if his ambition
to forge a wildly new life
for himself with her is
something that explodes in him like he's
realizing
how dead his life had been before
because he was just
even though he was dissatisfied with the
job in many ways
he was still just nose to the grindstone
numb
plotting ahead and he's like how did i
ever
live like that for years and years i
couldn't go back to another
second of that i'd blow my brains out
it's like yeah she's
trouble but i can't go back to nothing i
can't go back to
an emotional vacuum anymore i kind of
stuffed myself into that to forge ahead
but
i don't fit in that room anymore
conflict with a god that's always
interesting because
it doesn't necessarily have to have any
kind of connotation
any kind of religious connotation it
conflict with god suggests a religious
connotation
but it's just any time there's something
going up
against a bigger power it could be you
versus the neighborhood
bully it could be trying to get you know
something
done against city hall
[Music]
so that it's these are very flexible
the less literally you take these the
more actual use you can make
make of them so you want to have a
poetic or metaphoric frame of mind as
you look at these
you don't want to be stuck with their
actual definitions
at all if you look at one of these
things
even if it's not a valid
chain of logic that you look at one of
these things and it gives you 10 ideas
those 10 ideas are what's important this
is just a catalyst
in chemistry a catalyst is something
that you throw into a chemical mix and
it creates
a reaction even though the original
catalyst stays the same
so even if this triggers
makes you think of something that
happened to you as a kid which makes you
think of a weird possibility for your
story
which triggers dynamic possibilities for
the ending you've been stuck on
it doesn't matter how this triggered a
chain of thought that got you there
their job is to throw gasoline on the
fire and trigger stuff
and that's that's its only function
really it's just a brainstorming tool
it's just to expose you to the elements
that are already active in your story
even if you hadn't noticed that already
and to expose you to possibilities that
you wouldn't have thought of in 20
lifetimes
things that you never would never have
occurred to you
that all of a sudden are like wow that
could really tweak my third act
i've been dying for something like this
you know it's just like
it's it's throwing hand grenades into
your story idea
erroneous judgment is very central in
this story look how big it is before you
touch anything
because he's like he's looking at her
going
am i crazy or is she like
the most exciting thing in the history
of mankind
or am i like ready for a freaking
straight jacket
and like her too you know it's like i
don't even know which way my head
screwed on anymore
and like the things that i'm
contemplating doing with her
and overturning my job and committing
treason and blah blah i was like
i don't know whether to shoot myself or
run off with her and
have 20 kids like i don't know what i'm
thinking anymore
recovery of a lost one is he going to
get his own
sense of self back loss of loved ones
is he going to lose her is he losing
himself is he losing his sense of honor
so these are like
you want to have a really flexible frame
of mind when you look at them because
you'll get so much more out of them
it's like the wrench doesn't have to fit
the bolt head exactly if it'll turn it
you know even if it kind of fits and
it'll turn it that's all you need you're
just trying to advance your story
or to see more deeply into it because
you're penetrating into the
inner elements that constitute your
story
this tool is really useful
when you're starting a story from
scratch
because say you're
riding on a bus and you hear the two
people in front of you talking and it's
a whacked out conversation
and you're kind of listening in because
it's so interesting and one of them says
something and you're like
that would make an amazing screenplay
holy crap you rush home and you're like
boom oh i gotta you just go on a mile a
minute
that's a great time to go to the 36
dramatic situations
because you're exploding with ideas and
if you look down the list of the 36
you'd be like
that's already in there that's already
in there i didn't know that's in there
but
boy is that potent and
could that be in there that would really
whack it out in a completely dangerous
way or make it more hilarious or
whatever the story is going it's like
god
that is pure dynamite and it's like your
head's already exploding with ideas
and you're tossing explosive elements
you're playing mad scientist
with explosive elements and you may hit
one of them and you're like
that can't be or could it you'd be like
that's scary that's truly terrifying
i i don't even dare think then but you
can't get away from me you're like
okay well what if i did do that you're
like so
it may trigger 100 ideas it's like one
of them can give you a cascade of ideas
like you can barely write them all down
you're already cascading with ideas and
this is throwing gasoline on the fire
you're throwing explosive elements into
the mix playing what if
and so if that one
idea gives you 10 ideas and each of
those gives you 10 ideas
get all that stuff down on paper that's
what's important
that thing doesn't mean anything it just
got you thinking
so it's a extremely valuable
brainstorming tool
in part because you're being exposed to
one complete spectrum of
ideas because where the idea originally
came from gazi said
this these 36 dramatic situations
are every element that is in any story
anywhere
and a lot of people said that's insane i
could come up with way more and they
tried to come up with a list and they
couldn't even get to 24.
they were like actually it's better than
i thought and then schiller and gerta
both said
this is amazing and so it just hung
around
and it's it's just a tool it's just
one complete spectrum of ideas
that you can whip out and use
to trigger ideas for your story and to
see
elements in it that you hadn't noticed
so that
you're going wow this idea was deeper
and more complex than i thought at first
glance there's
more going on there than i noticed at
first
which is great because then you've got
better material
you've got more to work with if you're
doing a tv series you're like exploding
with
seasons and you know cliffhangers
and characters these things can suggest
characters they can suggest resolution
they can complicate dilemmas
but it's just one complete spectrum of
possible ideas
so it's not the be-all and end-all it's
not the only place to look for story
ideas
it's just one tool
and not only is it useful when you're
starting out on an idea
but it's useful to take a quick run
through the one sheet every now and then
just like part way through your script
you may go back and look through it and
go
a crime pursued by vengeance that's
emerging as a much more substantial
aspect of the story and i hadn't really
thought it through yet but
so it can it can just shake things loose
or help you solve things you've been
wrestling with or
expose you to possibilities that might
never have occurred to you
or help you see that this element is
very active in the story if you hadn't
noticed it yet
and then when you get stuck at
different parts of the story where
you're really stuck on your third act or
something
going back through it can shake things
loose clarify things
open up possibilities help you see
things that are in it
that you hadn't noticed before that kind
of thing
so it's a it's really an
explosive brainstorming tool and you
want to have
broad flexibility with it a real sense
of play
not feel trapped by any of it it doesn't
dictate anything to you
it doesn't say this has to be in there
and even if at the beginning of the
story you were like wow ambition
is right at the nucleus of this story by
the time you've worked on it for a while
you may
come back and look at it again and be
like ambition doesn't even matter
anymore it's like
i thought that was huge but it's grown
and changed so much
so you're not it's it's just
it's just like getting
blown in the air by explosives at
certain points in the development
process to
shake things loose trigger ideas help
crystallize things clarify
things simplify things complicate things
and that's all part and parcel of the
normal storytelling process
anyway this is just some good chemicals
to throw in there that are like
fertilizer
or clarifying agents or
complicators or clarifiers
so you see it in super clarity all of a
sudden like it can take a while
spend time with the story for quite a
while before you get
true clarity with it like um
sydney pollock when they were working on
tootsie
spent a long time trying to figure out
what the story's really about
and it wasn't until it finally dawned on
him that
becoming a woman made a man out of
michael dorsey
that all of a sudden it like
crystallizes like ah now
i know in really simple terms that's
what the story is about
and he said i went back and looked at
every scene and like how does this scene
work with clarify amplify solidify
the idea that becoming a woman makes a
man out of michael dorsey
and he said it helped a lot in terms of
working with the crew working with the
actors
his own understanding of it and he said
it doesn't mean the story is going to be
good
it just means that i know what it's
about that helps me so much as a
director
you